[Musique]
qui dans des salles aimerait être
accomplis sur le plan professionnel qui
souhaiteraient en effet dépendant
financièrement qui veut avoir une
famille épanouie qui veut que sa vie
quand ou tout simplement qui me réussit
bien
[Musique]
est ce que vous connaissez la clé pour y
arriver pour construire un avenir
meilleur
et bien ce soir nous avons tous de
réfléchir ça peut vous paraître anodin
mais nous l'avons tous en nous nous le
fixe on reconnaît bien la seule
différence
statham est ce que vous avez une idée de
ce dont il s'agit je sais que dans cette
salle il ya personne n'y pas fait de
plans de la journée si vous êtes là
c'est parce que vous avez qualifié
quelques heures ou quelques jours plus
tôt quelques saint roch motivation ainsi
vous vous êtes fixé un objectif à très
petite échelle sableux venons tous au
quotidien
il ya eu une chute été réalisés sur les
étudiants en nba de havas qui a montré
que les personnes qui s'occupaient des
objectifs 2010 et six fois plus que ceux
qui ne le font pas si on continue avec
votre plan d'assister à cette conférence
pour y arriver
vous allez penser à comment arriver sur
les lieux donc pour certains c'est de
venir en voiture ou pour d'autres cette
paiement de l'argent pour payer le
transport
vous avez également penser à comment
accéder à la salle
vous aller s'acheter indiqué vous avez
reçu une invitation ainsi à chacun
construit un objectif on se donne les
moyens pour y arriver on se prépare les
supposés peu comme vous avez acheté
votre site et il ya quelques dixièmes
l'offrir
waouh quelque chose vous
alors d'utiliser l'argent tout vous avez
pris un spécifié pour autre chose
si vous n'aviez pas pu venir à cette
conférence vous allez interpréter sedan
de ticket com votre chiot tour tout sauf
d'argent ce n'est pas en réalité
la chose n'est rien d'autre que la
réponse de l'opportunité des réparations
j'aimerais monter une histoire il ya
trois fous qui ont décidé de s'évader
d'un hôpital psychiatrique
il ya les deux premiers qui sont
convenus sur le jeu et sur la stratégie
ils se sont dit c'est le gars qui se
trouve à droite
d'abord on lui reparle à gauche s'il
garde la me trouve à gauche d'abord
passer par là doit être le jour qui
arriva il ya le troisième fouquy à la bt
de la combustion du gardien revient sous
frise les larmes aux yeux et dit au 2e
en de base ont vu qu'aujourd'hui parce
que le gardien n'est pas là vous
l'imaginez le garder les ballons ils
étaient chance mais vu qu'ils ne se sont
pas préparés ils sont passés à côté de
cette chance donc la semaine dernière
d'autres que l'enfant de l'opportunité
et de la préparation
frick gros objectif quelques vous faites
vous donner beaucoup plus de moyens
d'aller beaucoup plus de préparation nsa
s'imagine tout l'enjeu n'est pas le même
pour vous qui me regarder et pour moi
qui suis sur ce podium
vous allez pourquoi nous fermons
continent j'ai prévu dix tenues et 10
paires de chaussures parce que
j'aimerais pas venir ici pieds nus ou en
boitant juste parce que j'ai perdu un
ballon mais puisque je tiens vraiment à
ce que ceux ci je réussis
je me suis beaucoup plus préparé une
leçon qu'il ya très peu de gens d'ici
qui ont prévu une tenue de rechange donc
quand on a un gros objectif
en skiff plusieurs plans pour y arriver
et parce que je vais le démontrer tout à
l'heure que la chance ne regarde que la
rencontre de l'opportunité et de la
préparation on a plus de chances
d'atteindre le top 10 mais non parce que
vous avez plusieurs plans vous accepter
l'échec
vous savez aussi leblanc a mal joué
c'est le camp à l'âge où vous allez le
plan b vous verrez pas ses sympathies
menthe donc développé une acceptation à
l'échec et dont vous êtes plus plate
révérend dans une cuve on a demandé à
des étudiants de réaliser les actions
les plus improbables notamment de
demander à un passant dans la rue
delambre assis ou d'aller dans un hôtel
de luxe et de vouloir réserver la suite
au prix de la chambre simple ils étaient
préparés et ils savaient qu'ils allaient
retrouver pour cette raison ils ont
insulté vite et ils n'ont pas pris
personnellement et plus tard l'aîné
remarqué qu' il était plus persévérants
donc l'objectif grand que vous fixez
vous permet d plus persévérants mosconi
pas de personnes qui aient eu du succès
sans être persévérant si on prend
l'exemple de thomas edison qui alimente
des landes bull la louve est la solution
aux maux 2
le natif mais quand on lui demande et
vie il aimerait que mille solutions qui
répondait pas à son problème parce qu'il
a été attribué
de la même manière parce que l'objectif
est grand et que vous avez plus un plan
vous prenez plus de risques dit parce
que lorsque l'on m'a dit oui il ya le
deuxième plan ekissi amoudry 10
caractères des personnes qu'il est nous
avons des gens comme moi mais gandhi
martin luther king qui a fait de
conditions aux rites et leur vie au nom
des bâtiments auxquels tiennent nous
adorons des idoles comme steve jobs qui
ont risqué leur manière en abandonnant
l'écho pour commencer à fabriquer des
machines dans leur garage
on ne connaîtrait pas l'iphone ou le
macbook
s'il avait pas frissonner les personnes
il existe une friendly est maintenant
vite montré que leur objectif est gros
plus on a un plan donc on a plus de
choses on ne veut plus persévérants et
on prend plus de riz donc des caractères
du personnel mêlant qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à vous tous et l'objectif aussi
grand
c'est la confusion kong où la confiance
que vous allez on vous projets et les
teams ont très peu quand on se disait
petite zone d'objectif et qu'on les
réalise des petites victoires là
augmenter la confiance en soi
donc au bout de six ans un très grand
objectif impulsivement vous développez
votre confiance en vous et donc le sous
des conditions plus de faire fi des
rentes plus vous avez des chambres de
ria plus vous prenez le risque plus vous
avez confiance en nous maintenant j'aime
raconter mon expérience vous avez
toujours voulu changer le monde tu veux
rendre le monde meilleur
tu ne t'es pas de même cette idée mais
je pense que c'est parce que j'étais
petit
et comme on est tous en très grand bay
les mots clés que tous les ans devant
nous très ambitieux et il n'y a que par
la suite que la société a mené des
obstacles des idées reçues
unibel et ambition je me suis dit ces
deux plans pour y arriver
le premier c'est de me tailler dans un
domaine en particulier le deuxième cd
demandent les gens autour de moi
beaucoup plus heureux qu'ils aient des
jeunes dont le premier vol est plus
facile pour moi mettre en oeuvre c'est
ici que j'ai choisi de faire carrière
dans un domaine où la femme est peu
représentée jeudi nie pas être major est
la seule fille de ma promotion avoir une
maîtrise en mathématiques
après quatre années à l'université de
lomé pendant l'année de mépris j'ai été
convoqué par la doyenne de la faculté
des sciences à la réunion mais parce que
j'avais vu la meilleure au monde on
analyse fonctionnelle
c'est là qu'elle annonçait qu'elle
allait m'offrir une bourse complète qui
prenait en charge les frais de scolarité
médical personnel pour continuer mes
études en france
j'ai dit je veux pas que cette bosse
elle n'avait jamais employer quelqu'un
au mépris sont allés aux étudiants en
dernière année de thèse de doctorat
c'était très gentil de me salis pourquoi
mais parce que le sucre et paris y
compris à moi américain qui appelle une
réflexion j'ai remarqué que j'étais loin
d'atteindre mon objectif de changer le
monde tu es devenu le mal que je
travaillais au nombre de marchés
appareils canadien magna mais j'avais
pas l'impact que je voulais avoir donc
c'est ainsi que j'ai misé domaine en eu
mon plan b qui était de rendre les gens
autour de moi heureux bien un titre et
les mots l'entreprise qui est
spécialisée dans les études de marché
analyse
pour créer de l'emploi aux gens y avoir
plus de rome je sais que j'ai encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour changer
le monde mais j'y crois et je respecte
il est rond tu sais que je reviendrai 10
obstacles collecter de la zep
l'adversité mais qui amène aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vraiment que vous fixez vous
des objectifs fixés les sites grand que
vous pouvez pour construire un avenir
meilleur
pas n'importe lequel votre avenir et ils
augmentent elles soyez ambitieux
[Musique]